es la verdad
se enfrentan en la final de la
libertadores el campeonato de fútbol más
importante del continente
desde 2011 si lo hace hoy será otra
campeón si quería sentir la emoción de
estar cerca independientemente de no
poder ir al estadio yunta no estadio
quería estar en este ambiente río de
janeiro es fútbol
[Música]
en sao paulo los bares están cerrados yo
quería sentir el calor de los hinchas en
este partido
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y no estar en el estadio hoy para mí
significa mucho es la falta de la
hinchada
yo voy a todos los partidos de palmeiras
entonces estar aquí en río hoy es algo
que representa mucho yo represento a mi
familia y a mi escuela de samba la
mancha verde
[Aplausos]
es una sensación indescriptible estar
con toda la familia de palmeiras fue un
partido dramático hicieron un gol en el
último momento palmeiras bicampeón
[Aplausos]